pas trop décalé donc par rapport au
timing et désolé pour le petit quart
d'heure de retard donc Mesdames
Messieurs donc nous poursuivons
aujourd'hui notre nos travaux avec donc
cette troisième édition de l'après-midi
avec le réseau pour la transition
énergétique votre association elle a été
créée en 1984 dans l'objectif de
promouvoir les énergies renouvelables ce
dont témoignent votre premier nom le
comité de liaison pour les énergies
renouvelables même si vous restez
fortement impliqué sur ce sujet en
particulier vous êtes rapidement
positionné sur toute façon plus générale
l'ensemble des questions de transition
énergétique vous êtes ainsi connu pour
avoir fondé en 2011 le réseau des
territoires à énergie positive cette
idée a été ensuite reprise en 2014 par
Ségolène Royal alors ministre de
l'écologie que nous avons d'ailleurs
auditionné le mois dernier l'idée
derrière les territoires es à énergie
positive et de réuni réussir à penser de
manière systémique la transition
énergétique en parvenant à la mettre en
oeuvre au niveau de plusieurs
territoires pilotes
concernant le sujet de notre commission
d'enquête vous êtes positionné à
plusieurs reprises en faveur d'une
accélération des politiques de
rénovation des bâtiments vous écriviez
ainsi dans l'éditorial du magazine notre
énergie paru en automne 2022 profitons
du bouleversement de la politique
énergétique française et de la révision
de la stratégie française énergie climat
en cours pour faire enfin de
l'efficacité énergétique une réelle
priorité vous faites un travail
d'information sur la question et vous
participez à la réalisation d'études sur
la rénovation énergétique dans les
derniers mois vous avez notamment
consacré deux notes sur la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments dans la plus
récente qui est parue en janvier 2023 et
qui a été réalisé avec l'ascenseur
Negawatt que nous venons également
d'auditionner avant vous vous concentrez
sur le sujet des pompes à
vous soutenez que l'installation d'une
pompe à chaleur sans isolation thermique
en parallèle est inutile dans la mesure
où elle ne peuvent pas fonctionner si la
chaleur requise des radiateurs et trop
élevé qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé à vous
intéresser à ce sujet en particulier
quel jugement portez-vous à ce titre sur
le dispositif ma prime rénove qui en
excluant ma prime rénove sérénité
finance majoritairement des changements
de chauffage dans une note de mai 2022
vous êtes également intéressé au service
public de la rénovation de l'habitat
vous faites le constat que
l'articulation entre les différents
acteurs et complexes et qu'elle a
globalement et qu'elle est globalement
insuffisante pour accompagner
efficacement les personnes faisant des
démarches de rénovation énergétique
pouvez nous pouvez-vous nous rappeler
les raisons qui vous avez poussé à
formuler ce constat entre temps un
arrêté relatif à la mission
d'accompagnement du service public de la
performance de la performance
énergétique de l'habitat était pris le
21 décembre 2022 il précise l'émission
de l'accompagnateur ainsi que les
conditions de délivrance de l'agrément
et ces modalités de contrôle les
dispositions de cette arrêtée vous
semble-t-elle suffisante
quels sont selon vous les pointes de
blocage qui demeurent dans le
déploiement du service public de la
rénovation de l'habitat avant de vous
laisser la parole pour répondre à cette
première question et pour un propos
introductif d'environ une quinzaine de
minutes il me reviennent vous indiquer
que cette audition est diffusée en
direct et en différé sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'un compte-rendu
sera publié mais je dois également vous
rappeler qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête serait
passible des peines prévues aux articles
434-13
434-1 14 et 434-15 du code pénal qui
peuvent aller de trois ans à 7 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 45000 euros
d'amende à 100000 euros d'amende donc je
vous invite à prêter à dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité et à lever la
main droite et à dire je le jure
je vous en remercie donc je vous cède la
parole et ensuite monsieur le rapporteur
vous posera un certain nombre de
questions complémentaires
et bien bonjour à toutes et tous donc
moi je suis Marie-Laure Lamy je suis
vice-présidente du réseau du clair et
j'y suis parce que je suis directrice
d'une agence locale de l'énergie et du
climat qui s'appelle alohann et qui est
situé sur la Bretagne Sud
en introduction je voulais rappeler et
compléter cette très bonne introduction
de qui est le réseau du clair le réseau
du Clair est aussi à l'initiative de la
création du réseau des conseillers infos
énergie dès 2001 donc il y a plus de 20
ans en collaboration avec l'ADEME donc
ce réseau qui a formé animé et fait
monter en compétences les conseillers
qui œuvrent auprès des habitants de tous
les Français qui souhaitent rénover et à
l'époque même qui souhaitait construire
leur habitat donc c'est à ce titre aussi
qu'on a beaucoup de choses à amener à
cette commission et on est vraiment
ravis d'être audité parce qu'on a plein
de choses à vous dire et à partager avec
vous
peut-être en complément vous dire les
deux points sur lesquels on a envie de
focaliser nos discussions et on sera
bien sûr ouvert à toutes les questions
après
le premier point c'est ce rôle
d'accompagnateur à la rénovation
énergétique donc ce service public
d'efficacité énergétique de l'habitat
donc ça ça va être notre premier point
en lien avec mon accompagnateur Renov
donc là j'interviendrai pas mal parce
que c'est mon travail au quotidien donc
c'est un témoignage non seulement
véridique mais un témoignage concret de
tous les jours et puis en deuxième
partie on vous parlera des notre point
de vue sur les aides à la rénovation
globale et performantes et là
j'introduirai et je laisserai Isabelle
et Daniel complétaient parce que là ils
ont fait des études beaucoup plus
concrètes que moi sur le sujet
donc grand 1 mon accompagnateur énorme
le service public de l'efficacité
énergétique de l'habitat ce que
j'aimerais rappeler en introduction
c'est que depuis le lancement du
programme SAR service d'accompagnement à
la rénovation énergétique qui doit dater
de
20 ouais on a commencé en 2020 l'État ne
met plus de budget dans ce service
public d'accompagnement puisque c'est
financé par les certificats d'économie
d'énergie et par les collectivités
locales aussi bien les régions que les
EPCI
donc ça c'est un premier point qui est
assez alarmant pour nous parce que ce
service public il a besoin de visibilité
de durabilité on a quand même ces
conseillers qui accompagnent les
particuliers au jour le jour dans leur
projet
sont des termitiens de Bac + 3 à bac + 5
former animer régulièrement formé qui
font aussi de la veille qu'on anime
comme on peut avec le réseau du clair
parce que c'est le premier contact du
particulier quand il commence à élaborer
son projet de rénovation puis en général
un projet de vie assez conséquent et
c'est aussi un tiers de confiance parce
que un conseiller alors je les appelle
encore les conseillers infos énergie je
vais essayer de m'appliquer ce sont
maintenant les conseillers France rénov
voilà donc les conseillers France
rénovent sont ceux qui vont sécuriser
accompagner répondre aux questions tous
les habitants et qui vont aider
les ménages à réfléchir aux travaux les
plus efficaces pour eux donc en général
un conseiller France rénov il parle de
la demande initiale du ménage et il va
l'amener à aller plus loin dans ces
travaux grâce à des renseignements
techniques mais aussi à des
renseignements financiers pour aider à
faire un budget en général plus
conséquent des travaux qui vont être
réalisés derrière aujourd'hui vous avez
en face de vous une directrice très
inquiète parce que ça fait maintenant 12
ans que je dirige cette association où
nous sommes 30 personnes salariés il y a
sur ces 30 personnes huit conseillers
France rénov aussi bien pour les
particuliers en maison individuelle pour
les particuliers en copropriété et pour
le petit tertiaire privé donc pour les
entreprises du territoire je n'ai aucune
visibilité sur les budgets que pour à
mobiliser l'agence ni même d'où
viendront ces budgets au 1er janvier
2024 sincèrement je ne sais pas
longtemps mettre dans mon budget
prévisionnel et qu'elle répond sa portée
assez Bac +3 bac + 5 qui ont cette
vocation d'accompagner les ménages dans
leur projet de rénovation aujourd'hui on
a une grosse incertitude ce sont des
gens formés compétents passionnés par
leur métier et aujourd'hui on a un
risque énorme de leur faire craindre
pour leur avenir et donc il ne reste pas
forcément dans nos agences je parle
d'Halloween parce que c'est de ça que je
connais le mieux mais c'est le cas de
toutes les agences locales de l'énergie
ou les associations qui portent depuis
20 ans ce qu'on appelait des Espaces
Info Énergie
Leclerc c'est un quart des espaces et le
Clair représente on me souffle dans
l'oreillette un quart des espaces France
rénov aujourd'hui donc c'est vraiment la
remontée qu'on veut vous faire on a on a
besoin de visibilité on a besoin de
pérennité sur ces missions qui ont un
taux de satisfaction de la part des
ménages accompagnés de plus de 80%
depuis 20 ans donc on a un service qui
fonctionne ça c'est le premier point sur
l'existant nous en Bretagne on pratique
le sar depuis 2020 il y a eu des bons
côtés des mauvais côtés le bon côté
c'est que maintenant on peut clairement
mieux évaluer le budget nécessaire pour
avoir un nombre de conseillers suffisant
sur les territoires le mauvais côté
c'est qu'on n'a pas de visibilité et
surtout qu'on a ce fameux paiement à
l'acte qui est très compliqué pour des
personnes pour des techniciens qui
accompagnent des ménages en fait je
pense que je vais rien vous apprendre
mais les ménages ne rendent pas dans des
cases ils n'ont pas tous besoin de la
même chose au même moment donc se
découpage en acte à un à deux à trois à
quatre à quatre bis ne correspond pas à
ce que à ce dont on besoin les ménages
donc les conseillers passent leur temps
à se contorsionner par rapport à la
grille tarifaire de combien va être payé
l'agence pour pouvoir quand même
répondre aux besoins et donner naissance
à des projets efficaces aussi bien d'un
point de vue économique social et
climatique c'est vraiment à ça que
servent ces conseillers et qui ont
toutes légitimité
aux yeux des ménages parce qu'ils n'ont
rien à vendre derrière c'est indépendant
de n'importe quelle équipement ou
matériaux à vendre et ça ça rassure
énormément les ménages je vais dire un
petit mot sur mon accompagnateur Renov
pour en avoir discuté aussi bien avec
Lana avec la DGEC et avec des
professionnels du territoire on ne croit
pas que mon accompagnateur rénove puisse
être
source de développement d'activités
économiques je comprends la nécessité de
faire mettre des marchés on passe notre
temps à ça à faire en sorte que la
demande des ménages soit plus qualifiée
et plus conséquente pour alimenter le
marché des professionnels de la
rénovation le problème c'est que les
ménages n'ont pas ce réflexe d'investir
dans les études préalables donc en fait
on ne voit pas de rentabilité à cette
étape d'accompagnement qui est
nécessaire pour que les travaux soient
fait correctement dans le bon ordre des
correspond bien aux souhaits des ménages
et aux caractéristiques techniques des
bâtiments qu'il y a à rénover par contre
on craint vraiment qu'il n'y ait pas en
face d'acteurs économique on a essayé
avec des diagnostiqueurs avec des
auditeurs on a essayé de travailler on
n'arrive pas à atteindre un niveau
d'engagement des ménages un niveau
financier pour payer le temps nécessaire
à l'étude thermique aujourd'hui on l'a
fait dans le cadre du SAR c'est le
fameux
A3 et à 4 bis et à 4 tout ça on le fait
aujourd'hui ça risque de tomber dans
l'escarcelle du marché avec mon
accompagnateur rénov
je vais essayer de classer mes idées la
première chose c'est que pour nous des
acteurs privés à but lucratif se
lanceront dans cette aventure si ils ont
moyen plus ou moins détournés derrière
de récupérer le temps qui ne sera pas
rémunéré dans la vente de produits ou
dans la vente d'équipements par le biais
de filiade ou de je ne sais quoi là oui
pour y avoir un accompagnement privé
payant s'il n'y a pas ça il n'y aura pas
de il n'y aura pas d'offre et le
deuxième point qui nous inquiétait
énormément avec mon accompagnateur Renov
c'est que si on revient en gardant le
mode de financement du Sart où les mêmes
niveaux de financement au fait que les
espaces conseils faire se limitent aux
actes A1 et A2 donc sensibilisation et
conseils personnalisés derrière on ne
pourra pas rémunérer les conseillers
autant qu'ils passent on prend beaucoup
plus de temps que ce qui est valorisé
aujourd'hui dans les actes que ce qui
est rémunéré donc c'est non seulement on
pense qu'on ne va pas y avoir d'O FFRE
privée qui va pouvoir se lancer et en
plus nous on ne pourra plus faire notre
travail puisqu'on ne sera plus rémunéré
pour ses actes là qui sont aujourd'hui
beaucoup plus rémunérateur que les actes
à un ou à deux je pense que je rentre
pas forcément dans les tarifs mais on
est à votre disposition si vous voulez
des détails dessus et comme j'ai déjà
beaucoup parlé
oui je peux apporter quelques points de
complément sur des services publics
merci d'avoir pris connaissance de nos
notes
donc vous savez déjà un certain nombre
de positions que l'on porte et donc oui
en lien avec son mari-là a dit en fait
pour nous c'est important d'être attirer
l'attention politique sur la situation
de de l'écosystème de l'accompagnement à
la rénovation énergétique qui a connu en
fait des changements structurels et des
bouleversements assez important ces
dernières années donc à la fois le
défolisibilité sur la pérennité et la
pérennisation du service public via le
financement et en fait cette cette
situation est assez inédite depuis
depuis le lancement du service public en
fait les structures sont jamais
retrouvées dans cette position n'avoir
aucune visibilité à 9 mois en fait de la
fin de du programme actuel de
financement
et à la fois alors que parallèlement en
fait c'est vraiment un moment où la
demande est la plus forte des ménages
pour avoir cette des conseils et être
accompagné dans leur projet
oui et bien sûr en lien avec la crise
énergétique qu'on connaît et donc il y a
à la fois voilà cette défaut de
lisibilité
cette situation de mise en concurrence
qui arrive et qui crée des incertitudes
et une instabilité nouvelle et un
contexte de crise énergétique comme on
le disait et donc l'intérêt pour pour
les ménages d'avoir vraiment des
personnes en première ligne pour les
rassurer dans leur projet
d'où la nécessité vraiment de de
pérenniser et de renforcer ce service
public de la rénovation de l'habitat
et donc à la fois sur la question de
d'avoir des éléments de réponse rapide
sur la partie financement du service
public et sur la partie dispositif
d'accompagnement parce qu'on a compris
que ce serait deux enveloppes
différentes et là pour le moment on a de
la visibilité ni sur l'autre ce qui me
permet pas non plus aux structures de se
positionner sur le périmètre de leur
mission comme disait Marie-Laure il y a
les missions d'information de conseils
mais il y en a beaucoup qui se
rémunèrent sur les missions
d'accompagnement actuellement et ne
sachant pas comment est-ce que ça va
être rémunéré comment est-ce que ça va
être co-financé par les collectivités en
fait c'est difficile de se ce se
projeter voilà et de savoir en fait
enfin si il y a une viabilité économique
pour la structure et des un enjeu sur le
volume de ce financement donc le sar
arrive à son terme et
il est important en fait que le
l'évaluation de ce financement ne se
limite pas à l'enveloppe existante du
SAR parce qu'en fait il y a tout un tas
de missions qui n'étaient pas
comptabilisées dans ce programme en fait
c'était sous forme d'actes comme la
rappeler Marie-Laure sur l'information
le conseil l'accompagnement l'audit
énergétique etc mais en fait il y a tout
un tas de missions qui rentrent pas dans
le cadre de ce de ce programme et qui ne
sont pas financés et pour lesquels les
structures passent énormément de temps
donc tout le temps de management de
coordination de formation de
communication
tout ce qui va être conseil aux
particuliers pour la s'ouvre sur la
sobriété sur le l'installation d'énergie
renouvelable en fait tous ces éléments
ne rentrent pas dans le cadre du
financement actuel et donc il y a besoin
de d'avoir une réflexion aussi sur ces
missions là
en tout cas que le volume prévoit
de les couvrir
oui j'ai oublié de deux éléments
importants en vous donnant un peu de
chiffres c'est que quand on arrive à
faire des études entre comment quelle
était la demande initiale et où est-ce
qu'on arrive deux chiffres que je
voudrais vous donner c'est qu'on passe
de
1,3 actes de rénovation à trois actes de
rénovation à la sortie du rendez-vous
donc on voit bien que l'impact des
conseillers c'est de faire monter en
puissance sur la les travaux réalisés
et un autre chiffre intéressant c'est
l'équilibre entre l'argent public
investi et le développement économique
généré sur le territoire donc là on
avait calculé que pour 1 euro d'argent
public c'était 12 euros de travaux qui
étaient engagés c'était ça l'ordre de
grandeur donc ça c'est important parce
qu'on voit bien que dans ce travail de
sensibilisation accompagnement on a bien
la sécurisation du parcours pour
l'habitant on a des travaux plus
nombreux et plus conséquents et on a une
meilleure utilisation des fonds publics
ou non engagés dans les travaux c'est à
dire qu'on a une un meilleur usage de
l'argent public on sait qu'il est rare
aujourd'hui dans le développement
économique mais aussi dans la prévention
des enjeux climatiques sociaux
économiques qu'on a devant nous
allez on passe sur les aides
quelques points d'attention sur les
accompagnateurs de 9 puisque la question
nous a été posée donc on a participé
l'année dernière à la consultation qui
avait eu lieu sur
l'arrivée prochaine de l'accompagnateur
Renov la remise en place donc peut-être
faire un focus sur les points les plus
importants Marie-Laure on a commencé à
en parler la neutralité l'indépendance
des accompagnateurs donc ça c'est une
crainte que qui a été sous
la muraille de Chine
et qui reste une crainte pour nous parce
que le décret ne va pas suffisamment
loin à ce niveau puisqu'il y a la
possibilité pour des entreprises de
créer des filiales et de se faire agréer
et dans le même sens le niveau de
formation et les de compétences des
accompagnateurs nous ce qu'on demandait
c'était un référentiel métier avec des
prérequis en termes de formation en
terme de compétences notamment sur la
rénovation globale et performante
puisque le rôle des accompagnateurs
vanov sera d'accompagner les ménages
vers des projets les plus ambitieux
possibles de rénovation globale et il y
a aucun pré-requis en la matière ni dans
le décret ni dans l'arrêté donc ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on déplore également et
donc ces deux éléments niveau de
formation et neutralité
à une influence sur la capacité en fait
à orienter les ménages sur des parcours
de rénovation les plus ambitieux
atteignant le niveau de performance le
plus élevé au regard bien sûr de la
situation de de départ déménage
et on va passer au grand 2 les aides
financières à la rénovation globale et
performante juste avant de vous repasser
la parole si vous êtes meilleur que moi
sur les aides parce que c'est tellement
compliqué que même moi j'ai du mal à
suivre pour tout vous dire ça fait 12
ans que je fais ce métier là mais je
n'arrive plus à me mettre à jour c'est
le travail des conseillers France Renov
je vous rassure ils sont ils sont à jour
dans les informations mais je vais dire
quand on oppose pas du tout le monde
associatif privé à but non lucratif et
le monde privé habite lucratif il y a
aucun souci c'est qui est à la bonne
place et quelque chose qu'on a envie de
continuer à faire qu'on faisait quand on
était Espace Info Énergie qui est
beaucoup plus compliqué maintenant du
fait de cette tarification à l'acte
c'est de mettre en réseau les acteurs
locaux sur la rénovation et ça on sait
le faire on a maintenant une crédibilité
un bel échange avec les acteurs locaux
on est parmi les mieux situés pour
connaître les entreprises qui font du
bon boulot et qui font du mauvais boulot
on n'a pas le droit de le dire on ne le
dit pas aux habit ants on n'a pas le
droit on franchit la ligne par contre
sachez que nous les informations là on
les a les retours on les a et maintenant
nous pouvons parler des aides
financières à votre jouet
merci Marie-Laure merci madame la
Présidente effectivement le la mise en
contexte de notre association a été
extrêmement bien faite
on peut aussi ajouter quand même que on
fait partie des éléments moteurs sur la
lutte contre la précarité énergétique en
France depuis plus d'une quinzaine
d'années puisqu'on est les on héberge le
et on anime le réseau rappel donc des
acteurs de lutte contre la précarité
énergétique dans le logement depuis très
nombreuses années et c'est là où en
effet tous les éléments
que de bonification qu'on propose de la
politique actuelle en fait on ne sont
faites aussi dans un dans un but de
d'améliorer la situation des ménages les
plus en fragilités face à la transition
et à ce que ça exige en réalité
d'évolution et d'accompagnement que ce
soit sur la précarité énergétique que ce
soit sur les territoires énergétiques
que vous avez cité que ce soit sur
l'efficacité énergétique dans les
bâtiments on a une attention
particulière à embarquer les ménages en
fragilité les ménages modestes ou très
modestes comme on les appelle dans le
barème de Lana pour qu'effectivement il
n'y ait pas d'oublier dans ce chemin
vers la transition et qu'effectivement
on puisse éviter un certain nombre de de
risques on va dire politique également
qui sont qu'on a bien vu ce matérialiser
sur les 15 dernières années lorsqu'il
s'agit d'accélérer sur la transition
énergétique dans notre pays donc nous on
a une vigilance absolument particulière
à cet égard mais c'est aussi ça qu'on va
amener dans les dans notre regard sur
les aides pour le dire de manière assez
rapide quand même
actuellement pour nous
il y a un grand risque à poursuivre une
politique d'aide à la rénovation
énergétique qui ne viserait qu'un seul
indicateur qui est la décarbonation du
chauffage dans les logements pour nous
c'est une une politique qui est trop
restrictive en réalité les bénéfices de
la rénovation énergétique sont très
nombreux on l'a vu et particulièrement
qui résonne sur le plan de la
consommation d'énergie aujourd'hui dans
le l'épisode qu'on connaît depuis deux
ans qui nous permet en fait de nous
prémunir d'un certain nombre de risques
extérieurs qui nous permet aussi de
prémunir nos compatriotes
d'un risque de flambée des prix et des
factures pour les mettre en difficulté
sur le reste de leur vie
voilà et par ailleurs on le sait
maintenant c'est plusieurs études la
même qui ont des impacts en fait sur la
santé quand c'est bien fait qu'ils sont
considérables voilà et on peut on a une
kyrielle en fait de CO bénéfices qu'on
appelle les co bénéfices à la rénovation
énergétique qui sont difficile à prendre
en compte dans une équation financière
mais qui au niveau social doit être bien
pris en compte pour voir en fait quels
sont les différents effets de levier que
peut avoir une petite de rénovation
énergétique de l'ensemble des bâtiments
bien menés nous on est quand même
beaucoup plus spécialisés là et dans nos
interventions sur le logement privé
parce qu'on pense que c'est le segment
qui est le plus en risque
là où il y a le plus de choses à faire
et puis qui par ailleurs
représentent plus grand nombre de nos
concitoyens
voilà mais il y a aussi pas mal de
choses à dire sur les bâtiments publics
sur le logement social sur le parc
tertiaire évidemment mais on peut pas en
parler là donc
pourquoi pour nous ça devient très
important en fait de
continuer les orientations vers la
rénovation performante juste pour le
dire très rapidement en fait on a quatre
éléments fondament fondamentaux qu'il
faut faire impérativement progresser
pour avoir des effets généraux
au niveau des attentes des objectifs
qu'on s'est fixés qui sont quand même
très importants à l'horizon 2030 et à
l'horizon 2050 donc ce qu'on appelle les
éléments structurels donc
là on prend du temps sur deux qui sont
la question d'accompagnement et les
questions de l'orientation des aides
vers la rénovation globale et
performante mais il y a aussi tous les
éléments de communication qui sont très
importants et d'information
peut-être je pourrais revenir là-dessus
dans vos questions mais ça nous semble
très très important de bien dire ce
qu'est la rénovation énergétique aux
Français en quoi ça consiste et donc de
bien accompagner vers ces gestes là et
également un autre élément qui est très
important sur le capital on pourra
revenir qui est
nécessaire le nécessaire compagnonnage
de l'évolution de l'évolution des aides
avec l'évolution du cadre réglementaire
et on pourrait aussi prendre quelques
exemples
notamment sur les opportunités
d'obligation de rénovation qu'on peut
identifier lors des mutations qui
pourraient dans le futur devenir des
obligations sur la le renforcement du
cadre réglementaire sur les logements en
location sur un certain nombre d'autres
sur d'autres décrets voilà qui
accompagne en fait qui guide les choix
des et les possibilités des ménages en
fonction des bâtiments qui leur
permettent d'atteindre les bons
résultats aujourd'hui ce qu'on voit sur
les aides c'est qu'on a un déséquilibre
extrêmement important
des aides en faveur de gestes des
coordonnées d'une manière générale
au détriment finalement d'un d'un d'une
accélération sur la rénovation globale
alors ce qui est intéressant d'observer
c'est que au niveau du discours public
et politique c'est l'inverse en fait on
a un rattrapage finalement du discours
politique vers la rénovation globale
mais qui correspond pas à ce qu'on
observe sur l'évolution des aides ni ce
qu'on observe sur de quoi les gens se
saisissent en fait en réalité parce que
c'est normal l'influence du politique et
de la communication jusqu'au boutique
est très important dans le choix en fait
des individus il y a quand même malgré
ce qu'on dit une forme de de poids de la
parole des politiques et de et des
agences ou de l'ensemble des des acteurs
qui sont prescripteurs en fait en
réalité et donc quand la politique
publique elle s'oriente actuellement
dans un tel déséquilibre et là je vais
passer la parole à ma collègue parce
qu'en fait c'est ce sur quoi la dernière
étude que vous avez cité sur comment on
libère les bénéfices des pompes à
chaleur comment on fait aujourd'hui
d'une faiblesse une force dans le futur
[Musique]
en fait
c'est risqué en fait voilà c'est très
risqué d'avoir une politique qui ne qui
ne cherche pas à
aller vers le global et donc libérer
tous les tous les bénéfices potentiels
et même qui défavorisent au final quand
on regarde les aides vraiment dans leur
contenu donc ma prime rénov
essentiellement aujourd'hui la
rénovation globale par rapport à la
rénovation par geste ça a été un peu
corrigé lors du dernier de la dernière
loi de finances où on voit effectivement
là on commence à voir le passage dans la
réalité du renforcement du discours sur
la rénovation globale
voilà donc ça c'est principalement donc
voilà donc les aides actuelles en fait
elles sont pas alignées avec l'objectif
de rénovation performante en fait par
exemple une illustration c'est que il y
en a
aucune en fait qui est fléchée vers
l'atteinte du niveau BBC rénovation
pourtant ce sont les termes qui sont
utilisés dans les objectifs dans les
documents cadres de notre pays et là il
y a un découplage là il y a un problème
sauf à la marge on va dire avec des
petits bonus mais qui sont pas saisis je
vous épargnerais le le chiffre de qui
concerne les bonus d'atteindre du BBC
rénovation sur ma prime manœuvre on en a
suffisamment parlé ça fait l'objet de
controverse qui est pour nous sont pas
vraiment très pas intéressantes en
réalité parce que nous notre objectif
c'est pas de faire des controverses
c'est de faire progresser l'ensemble de
la politique publique donc on l'a dit le
montant de l'aide des aides pour la
rénovation globale il est trop faible ce
qui fait qu'en fait on a un problème de
viabilité économique en réalité alors
c'est moins vrai avec l'augmentation des
prix de l'énergie mais en même temps
l'augmentation des l'énergie ça retire
des capacités d'investissement au ménage
donc on se retrouve un peu voilà il faut
il faut aussi accélérer là-dessus un
tout petit complément ce que c'est
important sur les aides à la rénovation
globale le concret convaincre sur le
terrain c'est qu'en fait les ménages
n'arrivent pas à récupérer les aides au
final notamment sur les certificats
économie d'énergie aujourd'hui on a
encore eu des discours
de courtiers qui en fait spéculent sur
les aides à la Réno et basé sur les
certificats d'économie d'énergie et
mettent 6 7 8 mois à reverser les aides
au final on se retrouve avec des ménages
qui attendent les ailes pour pouvoir
payer les travaux donc sont obligés de
réduire ce qu'ils avaient prévu donc on
a un vrai souci on pourra en parler
aussi beaucoup avec ces certificats
d'économie d'énergie qui sont
malheureusement pas utilisés comme la
théorie économique le souhaiterait c'est
pas tout à fait ce qu'on voit sur le le
concret du terrain
là-dessus là et là l'accompagnement le
rôle de l'accompagnement et des espaces
conseils France rénov et clés parce
qu'en fait en plus de ça il y a une
complexité administrative une lourdeur
sur les le montage des dossiers de
rénovation globale et là il y a vraiment
des difficultés très importantes et le
enfin les retours terrain c'est qu'il y
aurait même pas en fait de dossier sans
accompagnement
voilà pour finir un peu sur le sur
l'état des lieux il y a aussi la
question donc de la dispersion des aides
en réalité le problème c'est pas
forcément alors peut-être d'autres échos
et puis on peut nuancer c'est pas
tellement le montant global des aides
publiques actuelles qui a un problème
plutôt que la capacité à s'en saisir
pour financer les bons projets ce que
nous on appelle les bons projets ceux
qui libèrent tous les bénéfices dont on
a besoin et donc ce qu'on appelle en
fait ça génère des coûts transaction qui
sont trop importants il y a une
dispersion finalement de l'énergie
consacrée à rassembler les aides par
rapport à se consacrer à son projet qui
est trop importante donc il y a une
question de réaligner les aides de mieux
les emboîter c'est un peu une arlésienne
mais ça reste encore vrai et il y a un
vrai problème de coordination entre de
grands ensembles que son ma prime rénove
les certificats d'économie d'énergie
sans parler du couplage avec et
l'alignement avec les aides locales qui
sont innombrables par ailleurs on a
toujours ce problème de reste à charge
très important pour les ménages modestes
parce qu'il y a aucune raison en réalité
alors que ce sont ces ménages là qui ont
plus besoin et bien souvent les dans
lequel ils habitent qui ont tous besoin
de proposer des solutions moins 10 ans à
séminin au prétexte que ben ils sont pas
dans la capacité financière non là il y
a une forme de subsidiarité collective
il faut franchir ce pas mais en réalité
le montant cumulé des bénéfices qui sont
générés pour la collectivité quand elle
se substitue au ménage y compris quand
il est propriétaire dans la rénovation
de son logement dépasse largement en
fait le montant qu'on investit à un
moment T donc ça c'est vrai que c'est
difficile à matérialiser comme équation
financière mais c'est la réalité c'est
ça a été mesuré voilà notamment par
rénovons voilà et par ailleurs ce qu'on
voit et là il y a un gros problème sur
les deux trois dernières années c'est
qu'on a des dispositifs nécessaires à la
lutte contre la précarité d'aide au
paiement des factures mais qui rentre au
volume auquel ils sont aujourd'hui fixés
en concurrence complète avec le
financement de la la
rénovation des logements et donc pour
nous aussi il y a cette idée c'est un
peu hors du hors du champ de de la
mission de d'enquête mais de ramener à
l'aide au paiement des factures à ceux
qui ont réellement besoin et quand même
de laisser jouer parce que en fait ça va
avoir des faits très bénéfiques le
signal prix de l'énergie sur un certain
nombre de personnes de ménages qui sont
pas en risque en fait d'augmentation des
énergies par contre sur leur passage à
l'acte sur la rénovation de leurs biens
ça peut être un déclencheur très très
important et aujourd'hui ça rendent pas
compte
[Musique]
donc voilà savoir un petit peu vous ce
que vous ce que vous pensiez par rapport
à ça en tout cas sur la stratégie à
mener pour pour arriver justement à
cette rénovation cette révolution
globale ensuite peut-être une aussi une
question sur vous l'avez un petit peu un
petit peu évoqué mais c'est pareil c'est
des choses sur lequel là pour le coup
puisqu'on a fait pas mal d'auditions
enfin auditionner la plupart des
ministres logements et de l'écologie sur
les dernières décennies
sur les choix qu'on peut être fait entre
l'interdiction enfin les moyens
coercitifs on va dire pour arriver donc
il y avait le choix de l'interdiction de
de location c'est ce qui a été c'est ce
qui a été décidé ou alors c'était de
dire on oblige à la vente à faire en
sorte que justement on puisse rénover
rénover des logements et ça se fait ça
se fera à la vente parce que c'est le
moment justement où il y a cette cette
possibilité là et donc le choix a été
fait plutôt sur l'interdiction de la
location voilà savoir ce que ce que vous
en pensez
je crois que c'était pareil je crois que
c'est François de Rugy qui était plutôt
sur enfin voilà qui avait plutôt lancé
cette idée de dire il faut vraiment le
faire à la vente en s'inspirant un petit
peu de ce qui peut se faire sur
l'assainissement avec le modèle despans
qui est de dire voilà quoi du coup il y
a une obligation de mise en conformité à
chaque à chaque vente et dès qu'il avait
pas du coup obtenu cet arbitrage et
qu'on était plutôt parti sur sur
l'interdiction des délocations et
d'aller vers ce sens là donc savoir si
vous aviez des éléments vous en tout cas
la vie là-dessus
et puis ça a été dit donc sur votre
votre réseau sur la mise en place au
départ des dépôts sur les territoires et
c'est vrai que c'était quelque chose
enfin voilà au-delà tout ce qu'on peut
se penser sur les dépôts mais en tout
cas quand il y a eu ce dispositif là on
a aussi auditionné
Ségolène Royal ça a permis de mettre en
place sur pas mal de territoires et
souvent de territoire assez petit plutôt
ruraux des plateformes de rénovation et
sur lequel enfin en tout cas moi tous
ceux que j'ai pu voir qui fonctionner
plutôt très bien justement parce que je
trouve que c'était des modèles assez
assez performants assez vertueux parce
que on avait de la de l'accompagnement
très de proximité du coup de la
confiance et et donc du coup des des
gens qui se lancaient dans de la
rénovation dans de la rénovation globale
de la confiance aussi avec les
entreprises parce qu'en général les
mêmes réseaux d'entreprise qui s'étaient
montés à côté je trouve qu'on avait des
exemples qui marchaient très très bien
et
pour voir un peu enfin pour avoir
rencontré c'est les mêmes aujourd'hui
ils sont tous assez désolé de dire qu'on
les a réorientés dans un système qui qui
a totalement bon ce que vous disiez
aussi des problématiques de financement
pour pouvoir pérenniser ce qu'ils
avaient mis en place mais surtout un
système avec le service le service
public de la rénovation de l'habitat en
lien avec les régions avec des du coup
des financements qui dont on sait plus
trop d'où ils viennent et ils arrivent
du coup à des performances très très
faibles en termes de de logement rénovés
par rapport à ce qu'il pouvait avoir
donc c'est vrai que beaucoup se posent
pas mal de questions je vais vous
préconisé dans votre dans votre rapport
que ça soit plutôt sur les services
publics de la rénovation de l'habitat et
que ça soit plutôt les régions du coup
qui soit animateurs et qui est le côté
financement
enfin moi je trouvais ça intéressant à
condition que vraiment on raisonne par
intercommunalité quoi parce que moi il
me semble que c'est vraiment le
l'échelon qui me paraît le plus
intéressant à la fois en termes de
proximité et donc d'avoir ce lien entre
région et interco mais il me semblait
que c'était quand même ça qui était qui
pouvait être intéressant donc voilà du
coup avoir votre avis aussi là dessus
merci
merci comme d'hab je commence et je vous
laisse confier derrière moi j'ai quatre
points en général j'en ai trois mais là
j'en ai quatre
le premier point c'est qu'aujourd'hui
donc on disait les aides à la rénovation
globale sont impossibles à enfin sont
très très compliqué à mobiliser ce qui
entraîne un déficit d'intérêt sur
l'isolation sur les travaux d'isolation
c'est beaucoup plus simple de mobiliser
des aides pour changer son mode de
chauffage et ça c'est une catastrophe
énergétiquement parlant commencez à
changer sa chaudière on va calculer sa
puissance sur l'état actuel de sa maison
ou de son appartement et derrière quand
on va rénover on aura une chaudière ou
un installation trop puissante ça c'est
du gaspillage et d'énergie et de
finances privées et de finances
publiques donc la première chose c'est
si on garde des des financements à
l'acte il faut qu'à minima ce soit
l'isolation qui soit priorisée dedans la
deuxième chose j'ai oublié d'en parler
tout à l'heure donc j'en profite là
c'est aussi
scénario bio sourcé dont on ne parle pas
assez pour relever les défis économiques
sociaux climatiques biodiversité énergie
qu'on a aujourd'hui faut qu'on arrive à
booster ces matériaux biosourcés d'une
parce qu'ils vont aller chercher des
ressources locales économe en
déplacement en transformation en un vrai
une des vrais filières à développer
aujourd'hui qui seront différentes d'une
région à une autre c'est aussi du
développement d'emploi et de compétences
en local donc c'est aussi un enjeu
économique et social on parle souvent à
tort des des biosourcés pour parler de
confort d'été même en Bretagne je me
rappelle que je viens de Bretagne la
question c'est pas le confort d'été
c'est l'habitabilité de nos logements
l'été y compris en Bretagne et là on
sait que les caractéristiques des
matériaux biosourcés sont très
intéressantes sur ça
le troisième point ce dont on a besoin
et j'ai bien aimé que vous citiez le
terme confiance donc en Bretagne on
avait avant le programme SAR développé
un grand nombre de ce qu'on appelait des
plateformes locales de la rénovation de
l'habitat qui avait donné naissance à un
truc fantastique c'est au rapprochement
des services énergies et habitats à tous
les niveaux dans les collectivités
locales mais aussi au niveau de la
région et ça c'était une source
d'efficacité énorme donc on a les on
connaît comment organiser les acteurs et
comment laisser la possibilité à chaque
écosystème d'acteur locaux de
s'organiser suivant les acteurs présents
et ça on l'a déjà fait donc c'est des
cousues il y a pas si longtemps que ça
on peut encore le faire mais faudrait
pas traîner pour pas se retrouver être
en concurrence en tracteur locaux ce qui
est en train de se passer
les aides lisibles quand je vous lisais
tout à l'heure enfin moi je suis
incapable aujourd'hui conseiller un
ménage parce que je ne connais plus
l'imbrication des aides c'est quand même
dingue ça fait 12 ans que je travaille
dans ce domaine là donc au moins des
aides lisibles compréhensibles et puis
la dernière chose que je voulais dire
c'est que ce qui a permis le sar par
contre c'est le Service d'Accompagnement
à la rénovation en énergétique là ce
programme de financement c'est d'aller
chercher
systématiquement la contribution des
collectivités locales donc on a
aujourd'hui 25% contributions locales
25% région et 50% certificat d'économie
d'énergie c'était pas le cas avant on a
toujours eu la région donc par exemple
mais là les collectivités locales
maintenant sont investis dedans sauf
qu'elles sont investies dans des
contraintes budgétaires qui sont pas
simples je pense que je vous apprends
rien sur les EPCI mais voilà quel est
l'avenir de ça en tout cas les
collectivités sont maintenant engagées
pleinement dedans comment rebondit
là-dessus de manière plus durable à vous
oui
alors je vais commencer par la dernière
question sur la gouvernance en fait du
service public doit apporter quelques
petits points complément va
effectivement nous on pense que
l'échelon régional et le bon et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on proposait de de
d'instaurer une compétence obligatoire
en fait pour les régions de pilotage
animation et co-financement du service
public mais on est tout à fait d'accord
avec vous que sur la mise en oeuvre
c'est les EPCI alors nous les
collectivités infra et régionales ce
qu'on intègre aussi les départements
dedans parce qu'en fait en fonction des
territoires ils sont quand même aussi
très impliqués dans la mise en service
public et donc voilà avoir ce
cette compétence obligatoire au niveau
de la région mais dans la mise en oeuvre
opérationnelle dans l'organisation du
service public que ce soit une
gouvernance partagée avec en lien avec
ses collectivités infras régionales
et pour répondre ensuite à votre
question sur les aides est-ce que on
trouve pertinent de conserver des aides
sur les gestes de travaux alors je
pourrais faire le lien justement avec
nos travaux sur les pompes à chaleur en
fait pour nous
sur des gestes isolés non mais sur des
gestes qui permettent au ménage de
rentrer dans un parcours de rénovation
performante par étape là ça s'entend
et je fais le lien parce que tout à
l'heure madame la Présidente ça nous a
posé une question laquelle on n'a pas
encore répondu ce pourquoi qu'est-ce qui
nous a poussé à choisir ce sujet en fait
plusieurs choses donc il y a eu le
constat de en fait le contexte
réglementaire et favorable à de plus en
plus favorable à l'électrification des
usages à la fois par la nouvelle
réglementation environnementale
sur les aussi en fait sur les
dispositifs d'aide et là quand on prend
les chiffres c'est assez implacables en
66,5% des travaux engagés pour ma prime
rénov concernant un changement de
système de chauffage contre seulement
20% pour l'isolation donc en fait c'est
tous ces constats là qui émanent du
terrain les conseillers observent cette
tendance et voilà une crainte en fait
parce que les les aides à l'isolation
baisse et à ce focus qui se fait sur la
décarbonation des usages
et donc pour nous sévère important de
creuser ce sujet et d'essayer de
comprendre les limites de cette
politique et en fait donc l'objectif de
cette note c'était pas du tout de de
jeter le discrédit sur les pompes à
chaleur au contraire en fait c'est de
montrer que c'est elles ont vraiment un
jour enfin une technologie qui a un rôle
majeur à jouer dans la des carbonations
de du chauffage dans la décarbonation
même des bâtiments plus largement
mais ce sera le cas ce sera d'autant
plus le cas si elles sont couplées à une
rénovation performante et donc là les
donc en fait c'est la note s'appuie sur
une étude une modélisation de différents
scénarios d'installation de différents
diverses technologies de pompes à
chaleur couplé ou non à une rénovation
et en fait on voit quand
il y a vraiment la combinaison
rénovation performante et installation
pompe à chaleur les impacts sur tous les
indicateurs que ce baisse des
consommations d'énergie énergie primaire
et finale baisse des réduction de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre réduction également de la
pointe électrique en fait c'est vraiment
tous ces indicateurs quand il y a
couplage c'est là où on va avoir les
meilleurs performances et de très loin
ça je vous invite à
c'est bien
démontrer dans la note via des
graphiques et donc dans ce cadre là on
fait un certain nombre de
recommandations pour
limiter on va dire le le enfin encadré
plutôt en fait c'est pas limité c'est
encadrer le développement de des pompes
à chaleur sur le territoire et permettre
en fait justement favoriser le couplage
rénovation performante et installation
de pack et donc peut-être rapidement un
rappel de ces recommandations donc via
l'introduction de d'un critère technique
de
de température minimum à des émetteurs
de chaleur à introduire dans les aides
publiques et privées donc à la fois ma
prime rénov et les certificats
d'économie d'énergie
et ensuite de
favoriser de réorienter massivement les
aides vers la rénovation performance
donc ça Daniel pour appuyer et donc
justement en privilégiant pour favoriser
le couplage et ben ça doit justement
passer par installation de pompe à
chaleur oui adossé à deux gestes de sur
le l'isolation de l'enveloppe et la
ventilation par exemple
et le
les autres recommandations où c'est
aussi incitation à la à l'installation
pompe à chaleur ho-o parce qu'elles ont
le meilleur performances à contrario
limité l'installation de pompe à chaleur
haute température ou pas chaleur hybride
qui vont être justement moins
performantes et les limitée à des
scénarios assez spécifiques dans les par
exemple impossibilité de rénover de
manière performante
et ensuite les autres recommandations
donc ça c'est surtout les
recommandations concernant les
dispositifs d'aide et ensuite on a une
recommandation sur le passage
obligatoire par un espace conseil France
rénov avant
changement de système de chauffage
justement en fait pour plusieurs raisons
en fait pour vraiment avoir
un conseil le plus pertinent sur son
projet de rénovation
et
neutre et et qui permettent également en
fait de de comment dire de
[Musique]
de mettre en garde les ménages notamment
contre le démarchage abusif et
téléphonique qui est interdit mais qui
reste une réalité malheureusement voilà
assez
intéressant parce que cette mesure là
elle nous est demandée par des plombiers
chauffagistes qui font partie du réseau
du clair de nous dire mais s'il vous
plaît demandez un passage obligatoire
par les espaces conseils parce que nous
derrière on est obligé de passer un
temps énorme pour déconstruire ces
fameuses suite de démarchage
oui donc voilà ça c'est cette
recommandation et les deux dernières
c'est sur le référentiel RGE donc
j'imagine que vous avez déjà dû en
parler également
d'accord
mais voilà on a des recommandations dans
ce sens là pour renforcer le référentiel
aller vers c'est ça aller vers des
méthodologies harmonisées entre les
installateurs et le dernier point c'est
sur la maintenance de d'accentuer la
communication sur la maintenance de
pompe à chaleur parce que en fait les
gens sont pas au courant que c'est une
obligation
merci je complète très rapidement pour
laisser encore une petite scène question
donc en effet je vais revenir sur la
question du palier parce que en fait on
a tendance à caricaturer notre position
nous on est pragmatique en fait on est
les 400 membres ou les plus de 300 à 400
membres du réseau du clair en fait sont
des praticiens de la transition
énergétique donc alors en théorise un
peu pour faire des recommandations mais
en réalité on est pragmatique ce qui ce
qu'il faudrait changer dans la logique
c'est bien de privilégier d'abord
d'avoir un système qui puisse permettre
de privilégier d'abord des rénovations
globales et performantes en une fois
puis des rénovations globales et
performantes ont plusieurs étapes puis
enfin laisser la porte ouverte
effectivement au geste mais dans cet
ordre là on fait l'inverse là on fait un
verset d'abord les gestes puis les
rénovations par étape et enfin et donc
l'idée c'est sur une évolution de
plusieurs années enfin on dit il y a
quand même des briques structurelles
assez importantes à faire bouger pour
qu'on puisse faire ça donc on peut pas
dire qu'on va le faire du jour au
lendemain et c'est parce qu'on demande
en fait on demande que on met en place
les conditions pour permettre à l'horiz
2030 de pouvoir effectivement signer
l'extinction du soutien au geste unique
à un horizon raisonnable parce que en
fait les défis qui sont devant nous
appellent à ce genre de réforme de la
politique publique
c'est un avantage aussi très important
sur les fraudes et les aides parce que
on en entend beaucoup parler ce qui a
tendance à jeter un peu discrédit
général sur cette politique publique on
pourrait y revenir et qui en fait
probablement finalement une petite
musique assez fausse en réalité c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de frauder ou de
proposer des offres un peu éthérés sur
la rénovation globale même par étape que
de le faire par geste il y a beaucoup
moins de place disons et ça c'est et ça
effectivement ce sera un moyen de
contrôler en fait les aides bien plus
forts pour les pour pour l'État que de
mettre en place des dispositifs de suivi
de contrôle qui sont plus de plus en
plus complexes on nous fait remonter ça
aussi et qui finalement pénalise plus
finalement les gens honnêtes enfin les
structures honnêtes que les spécialistes
de la fraude qui eux s'arrangent
toujours pour trouver le chemin pour
passer entre les entre les les Obs qu'on
leur met puisqu'ils sont spécialisés
dans la fraude en fait dans la montage
de dossiers administratifs et fiscaux et
pas dans les travaux voilà ou dans le
conseil
donc c'est ça donc nous nous pour dire
donc on est plutôt pragmatique je
voulais juste revenir aussi sur les
choix sur ce que vous avez sur les
émotions réglementaires parce que je
pense que c'est très important en effet
je pense pas que le choix il était
objectivement fait alors j'étais pas de
ce côté-là de la barrière j'étais plutôt
de l'autre côté parce que nous on est
effectivement on a été en grande
promotion d'abord dans l'interdiction de
location en 2019 la loi qui m'a énergie
puis de l'obligation conditionnelle de
rénovation énergétique en 2021
les deux les deux lois résonnent quand
même parce que l'une est un vrai
approfondissement de l'autre sachant
qu'au milieu il y a quand même la
convention citoyenne pour le climat qui
fait accélérateur et qu'effectivement
mais bien la lumière sur la précarité
énergétique pourquoi l'interdiction de
location dépasseoirs parce que on va
donner deux éléments importants un c'est
passeport en location sont en fait
l'approprier ça c'est l'in samedi de
ceux qui ont le plus moyen de rénover
leur logement et qui devrait en fait
dans une approche patrimoniale un peu
responsable mais qui n'est pas encore
tout à fait la culture française il
faudrait que ça devienne
et puis l'importance de la précarité
énergétique dans ces passoires dans ces
logements locations il y a une
sur-représentation massive des
situations de précarité énergétiques
dans les dans les logements passoires en
location donc les rénover ça fait du
sens que ce soit la première brique où
il y a un vrai renforcement et là il y a
un vrai coup de chapeau à tirer au
gouvernement en fait en réalité sur le
fait que pour l'instant ça tient voilà
et en vrai je sais que tout le monde ne
partage pas cette opinion et je vois
bien les difficultés mais il y a un vrai
signal aujourd'hui 30% des propriétaires
d'ailleurs sont prêts à passer à l'acte
de rénovation pour rénover leur passoire
avant cette dispositif à cette
disposition réglementaire c'était 0
voilà donc et ça c'est juste un élément
de de d'orientation supplémentaire de du
choix qui fait qu'on a un tiers de la
cible concernée qui décide de passer à
l'acte franchement c'est
parce qu'en termes de proportion une
fois encore une fois je dis c'est 10%
des passoires en location qui sont la
propriété de ménage qui sont modestes et
très modestes donc 10% c'est 90% enfin
et l'attention publique elle doit être
vraiment consacrée à l'accompagnement de
ces ménages là de manière à pas les
mettre dans une difficulté
extraordinaire sur l'obli et puis j'en
termine sur l'obligation conditionnelle
c'est à dire que pour nous
on pense qu'à un moment ou un autre il
va y avoir des des dispositifs
d'obligation mais on sait pas quand en
fait plus tard dans le temps là l'idée
c'était essayer de mettre l'attention
sur qu'est-ce qu'il faut mettre en place
c'était ça l'intérêt du conditionnel
pour pouvoir arriver un jour à une
obligation parce que sinon on met les
gens devant une impossibilité de
réalisation et ça c'est pas possible en
fait
du coup en fait ça évolue comme ça c'est
pas comme ça c'est que le l'obligation
conditionnelle l'opportunité
systématique de rénovation au moment des
de la mutation cibler sur les passoires
c'est quelque chose qui arrive après une
obligation générale c'est le fruit d'une
réflexion entre les pouvoirs publics et
la société civiles qui dit une
obligation massive aujourd'hui c'est pas
possible mais par où on commence et
effectivement tout le monde le dit le
moment de la transaction c'est le moment
où on fait les travaux c'est le moment
où le logement est vide c'est le moment
où les gens ils sont dans un projet de
rénovation qui peuvent être important
mais il faut qu'il calibre voilà il faut
qu'il soit bien accompagné il le serait
donc d'autant plus si on leur dit pour
toutes les passoires sans à 150 000
transactions par an quand même
on verra si ça continue comme ça
où là il y a un vrai signal politique à
envoyer pour dire là c'est le moment là
c'est le moment c'est un moment de vie
dans le bâtiment c'est un moment dans
votre vie évidemment faudrait convaincre
un peu les financeurs parce qu'il y a
pas que les aides publiques dans le
financement bah oui et bah il y a il y a
les ressources propres des ménages et il
y a la participation des acteurs du
financement
voilà dans cet effort là et aujourd'hui
on peut pas dire qu'il soit vraiment au
rendez-vous comme c'est 15 dernières
années en vérité il laisse les pouvoirs
publics se débrouiller avec le problème
et les ménages se débrouilles avec le
problème en oubliant complètement leur
mission de financement notamment dans
l'immobilier et dans le maintien en
gamme de la performance et aux normes en
fait des logements voilà
messieurs est-ce que vous avez des
questions François Calvez moi je l'avion
année la cause mais je contrôle pas les
horaires d'avion maintenant contrôle pas
grand chose d'ailleurs je m'aperçois
alors je sais pas si je serai dans le
tempo mais depuis le début j'ai assisté
à beaucoup d'entretien je m'aperçois moi
qui était parlementaire
l'assemblée au Sénat que si j'avais su
toutes ces lois je ne les aurais pas
voté
je les aurais pas voté parce que on
étudie la technique et tout ce que vous
dites après nous quand on a mis les
catégories j'ai machin c'est dans tous
ces normes on ne sait pas très bien ce
que ça comprend moi je j'avoue que on
avait fait personnellement peut-être que
mon collègue me dira on était en train
d'en parler un peu mais bon première
chose donc moi je vous le dis si vous
continuez à vouloir appliquer ces normes
aussi rapidement il y aura un
effondrement de tout le marché
d'ailleurs le rapporteur a dit tout à
l'heure
à parler des ventes qui les les
bailleurs vendent le plus possible leur
bien et alors il y a un endroit où ça
sera impossible c'est la montagne
moi j'ai tous les agents immobiliers qui
me préviennent de ce qu'on ne pourra pas
appliquer les normes que vous prescrivez
avant les dates c'est impossible et même
peut-être c'est impossible tout court
voilà parce qu'elles sont trop
importantes moi je vous parle de secteur
comme Font-Romeu je vous parle de
secteur qui
non non mais moi je te dis
je te dis ce qui se passe et sur le
retour que j’annais je veux l'exprimer
même si ça sert à rien sûrement mais
mais moi je veux le dire on va pas y
arriver parce que l'énorme qui sont
faites sont faites souvent pour la ville
pour des endroits nous on n'a pas du
tout les mêmes la même chose vous avez
pas on ne vit pas pareil voilà il faut
dans les bâtiments il faudrait peut-être
regarder un peu non mais attendez moi je
suis à Perpignan je viens d'éteindre le
chauffage bon ici on n'a pas été
comprenez bon c'est pas du tout pareil
voilà mon entier jamais compte on nous
impose d'énormes qui sont complètement
l'envers de ce qui de ce qui se passe de
la réalité du des situations locales et
géographiques moi je voudrais qu'elle
soit prise en compte parce que tout ça
fait que on aura un effondrement parce
que bon on pourrait penser que bon on va
construire notre nom on peut construire
donc problème est réglé donc il y aura
pas de construction nouvelle on nous dit
de rénover les logements en ville et
comment voulez-vous faire des
rénovations en prenant en compte toutes
ces normes personne ne peut les amortir
ni personne ne peut même pas même pas
les offices HLM donc encore plus donc
moi je suis pas très optimiste alors je
pensais la question mais cette question
me tarde depuis le début où j'entends ma
table de normes je suis en train de
m'affaisser sérieusement et je ne je
voudrais pouvoir relever la tête par
rapport aux gens que j'ai représentés
pendant 25 ans bon moi je vois que là
au fil des années c'est plus possible
voilà moi je le dis à ma façon mais je
vous le dis
merci madame la Présidente pour aller un
petit peu dans le sens de ce qui vient
d'être dit moi je pense que ça pose la
question de de
l'évaluation des impacts des textes que
l'on est amené à voter effectivement
c'est ce que dit
notre collègue
et il serait intéressant que dans le
cadre de la commission d'enquête
on regarde ce qui était à notre
disposition en matière d'études d'impact
par rapport à tous les dispositifs
auxquels on est confronté maintenant qui
sont à notre disposition et je pense
qu'on va en mettre très très surpris
parce que je pense que cet aspect là ça
vaut pour ce sujet comme pour beaucoup
d'autres ça fait partie d'ailleurs de
medada tu le sais je pense qu'on est
très faible dans notre pays en matière
d'études impact et que finalement on
amène le législateur sur des sur des
voies qui sont par ailleurs
absolument nécessaires parce que je
crois que ce sujet je le discute pas sur
le fond mais sur la façon dont on rentre
dans les sujets dont on ne se les
approprie et tentent tendu que infini
était en train de le vivre à chaque
audition le comment
fini par primer sur le quoi c'est-à-dire
la façon dont on s'organise pour y
arriver finit par être
sur les terminant quoi finalement par
rapport à aux résultats final on
s'aperçoit que encore une fois on
légifère en mettant la charrue avant les
bœufs quoi et je pense que ça c'est bon
pour personne c'est pas bon pour l'image
du du législateur mais c'est pas bon non
plus pour les acteurs directement
concerné par rapport à la mise en oeuvre
donc vous faites donc vous faites partie
donc je pense que ça serait intéressant
que la commission d'enquête regarde cet
aspect là si c'est si c'est possible
qu'est-ce qu'on nous promettait en la
matière par rapport à là où elle est
aujourd'hui et à ce qui reste à faire
parce que parce que derrière ça je finis
pardonne là-dessus
il y a aussi on en parle on en parle
très peu mais mais c'est fondamental
les volumes d'argent public qu'on va
pouvoir consacrer à ce sujet à côté
d'autres sujets qui sont tout aussi
importants par rapport aux enjeux de
transformation climatique diverses et
variées enfin voilà j'aime passer des
meilleurs on les a tous en tête un
moment donné je pense que compte tenu
l'état des comptes publics des hors
jours dès aujourd'hui on va pas pouvoir
tout faire et qu'on va être confronté ou
plus au niveau à des choix politiques
difficiles à faire mais qui seront
indispensables
et dans ce contexte là est-ce qu'un
sujet comme celui qui nous intéresse en
ce moment à la commission économique
devrait passer devant d'autres voilà qui
sont aussi importants ou tout aussi
importants voilà c'est la place de la
politique ça mais je pense qu'on va être
confronté à ça aussi et qu'il faut
peut-être pas laisser rêver voilà et ça
pose ça pose la question de la
faisabilité finalement parce que tu
disais François de la faisabilité des
d'ores et déjà des objectifs qui nous
sont assignés quoi
me semble-t-il c'est le rapporteur et
puis après on vous laissera le mot de la
fin
oui non merci c'est plus des par rapport
aux remarques qui viennent d'être faits
sur sur Skype ce qui était dit la
difficulté de mise en oeuvre en tout cas
de ce qu'elle puait de voter et les
différentes mesures qui ont été pris
c'est un peu justement le but de cette
commission d'enquête c'est de
s'apercevoir que que voilà pourquoi
justement on a eu un serveur peut pas
dire qu'il y a pas eu d'action politique
on peut pas dire qu'il y a pas eu
d'argent non plus on peut toujours dire
plus mais il y a eu il y a eu quand même
des milliards qui ont été mis qui ont
été mis sur la table il y a eu des
objectifs ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure
des objectifs très forts qui ont été
donnés
il y a quand même aussi un consensus
politique on le disait aussi c'est quand
même rare que sur un sujet comme ça tout
le monde soit à peu près d'accord en
tout cas pour dire il faut le faire il
faut y aller en tout cas c'est
intéressant et ben même dans ce cas là
on s'aperçoit que ça marche pas quoi
enfin en tout cas que ce qui a été mis
en place est loin des des de tenir les
objectifs donc moi c'est vraiment le but
justement de cette commission d'enquête
c'est essayer de comprendre pourquoi
alors c'est sûr que c'est pas simple ça
touche à différents à différents niveaux
mais je pense que l'idée de des études
d'impact en fait sur les différents
textes et de voir un petit peu ce qui
avait peut-être pu être imaginé en tout
cas être voilà et de voir ce que là
aujourd'hui ce que ça
comment comment du coup ça se ça se
traduit réellement dans les faits ça je
pense que ça peut être un aspect
particulièrement
particulièrement intéressant après là où
je mettrais peut-être enfin
c'est que on est quand même dans une
politique quand tu dis qu'il faut pas
faire rêver voilà je pense qu'on a quand
même la chance d'être sur un sujet ou
l'argent qu'on met ça a été dit tout à
l'heure je crois un euro va générer 12
euros en termes de travaux etc afin de
d'économie sur les sur les territoires
mais surtout c'est que les interventions
qu'on fait elles ont quand même si on
arrive à les faire correctement un
intérêt directement non mais je veux
dire
oui non mais je veux dire c'est que
oui mais
c'est par rapport au moyen nécessaire
pour arriver au bout de ce de ce
programme au demeurant absolument
nécessaire tu vois c'est ça il faut pas
il faut pas penser que
je pense que ça engage des sommes
absolument gigantesques quoi voilà et je
suis pas sûr qu'on l'ait bien mesuré
quoi après on n'est pas obligé de
partager
pour essayer de répondre à Monsieur les
sénateurs très très vite parce qu'en
plus vous avez raison alors
en réalité nous nous aussi en fait on
milite vraiment pour l'efficacité de la
dépense publique en vrai et pas
particulièrement dans ce dans ce secteur
là
parce que il y a effectivement des
bénéfices à attendre et il faudrait
qu'il soit au rendez-vous pour justement
en fait ne pas te tromper les gens c'est
pas tellement les faire rêver c'est
juste leur éviter des déconvenues sur
leur facture après investissement qui
sont très importants et alors en fait
quand même en réalité on a beaucoup
progressé en fait on est quand même dans
un domaine qui est très technique on
parle de bâtiment d'énergie on parle de
mode constructif on parle de schéma des
fois d'urbanisation et tout donc faire
progresser la statistique et la
connaissance publique via les données et
les outils qu'on a aujourd'hui conçu et
parfois grâce au céréma ou à d'autres
outils qui sont directement des outils
publics il faut continuer on a mis en
place l'observateur national de la
rénovation énergétique on déjà en place
l'observateur national de la précarité
énergétique c'est des outils qui
patiemment amènent à
équiper l'état de capacité de décision
qui sont beaucoup plus précises parce
qu'on met en phénomène en lumière des
phénomènes des potentiels des zones où
il y a beaucoup de passoires alors que
on était incapable de faire ça il y a
quelques années moi quand j'ai commencé
il y a 8 ans on avait pas assez donné là
on était dans la préhistoire de la
donnée de la statistique et ça a au
moins pour avantage des fois le le
numérique sert à quelque chose de
pouvoir justement appuyer l'État dans sa
prise de décision par la mise en lumière
de de de certaines données leur
rassemblement et là vous avez raison
c'est que de toute façon il y a des
exceptions il y a forcément des
territoires quand on parle d'atteindre
des objectifs on est en moyenne on n'est
pas sur un on est sur un en moyenne donc
ça veut dire que il y a des espaces où
en fait c'est possible des espaces où
c'est pas possible par contre sur le
fait qu'il faut rénover les logements
dans les territoires de montagne alors
il faut trouver les moyens de pouvoir le
faire en effet et ça demande
certainement beaucoup plus d'attention
et de moyens que dans d'autres endroits
vu la nature des contraintes qui peut y
avoir là aussi de toute façon je pense
que pour le bien-être des habitants il
faudra trouver les moyens de le mettre
en place alors c'est peut-être pas
forcément été prioritaire mais il faut
que ça le devienne
et sur l'évaluation de la politique
publique monnaie tout à fait d'accord
avec vous on est dans un pays où
ça n'a pas progressé suffisamment le
suivi évaluation des petites publiques
donc avec l'analyse par précise de
l'effet en fait des décisions qui sont
prises que soient réglementaires ou
l'investissement public en fonction des
indicateurs qu'on cherche à poursuivre
et nous on tient à rappeler qu'en fait
cette politique publique elle ne sert
pas qu'à poursuivre l'indicateur de
baisse
des émissions mais mais bien autre chose
et qu'effectivement on souhaite
ardemment par exemple que il soit mené
une étude qui rassemble et face l'état
des lieux de la mise en oeuvre des
réglementations existantes avec du pour
du contre et voilà tout à fait mais ça
ça n'existe pas on n'a pas d'études sur
la réglementation pour le renforcement
des contraintes ou des normes de
rénovation énergétique aujourd'hui on
n'a pas donc on peut pas faire ce
travail rétrospectif en réalité et ça
c'est pas les associations qu'on le
moyen de le faire en fait c'est vraiment
un travail de collaboration qu'il faut
développer pour lequel nous on est très
client et en plus on devient de plus en
plus spécialisé dans le travail le suivi
des travaux parlementaires ou des
exécutions budgétaires donc voilà
merci beaucoup Daniel et Isabelle
de questions j'ai le souvenir d'une loi
alors excusez-moi je me souviens plus de
de l'intitulé exact où on avait eu un
débat et ça n'avait pas abouti sur la
fiche c'était pas le terme utilisé la
fiche bâtiment
fiche technique
associée à chaque bâtiment
caractérise caractérisant en fait
c'était quoi le
passeport
avant mais après c'est revenu dans le
climat et c'était dans les Landes déjà
non on avait même eu la discussion
architecture de la création architecture
et patrimoine il y avait eu ça aussi et
c'est rentré d'un client alors pardon
parce que je réduis le je devrais le
savoir j'ai les loupé je pense à ça par
rapport à aux statistiques que vous
évoquez parce que ça c'est un outil
voilà très pragmatique qui s'il est bien
mis en oeuvre permet à terme de d'avoir
une connaissance du bâti fine et
permettant de développer des simulations
même s'il faut des modèles etc
rapidement
d'étude d'impact moi je suis économiste
à la base spécialisé en économie
publique et vraiment j'attire votre
attention sur les critères d'évaluation
qui vont être utilisés ce que la
rénovation énergétique il y a un côté
social réduction des inégalités il y a
un côté monté en compétences locales
utilisation des ressources locales
confiance entre les acteurs on en a déjà
parlé n'utilisez pas que des critères
économiques classiques la rénovation
énergétique elle amène des choses
beaucoup beaucoup plus riches notamment
sur les liens entre humains voilà ce que
je voulais dire merci beaucoup en tout
cas à tous les trois et puis bonne bonne
soirée et on a encore une audition qui
va terminer achever cet après-midi merci